you know we've become accustomed to sort
of lurid anecdotes of all kinds being
told at right wing rallies oh this
undocumented immigrant did this thing or
that thing or the other thing and sort
of used to the bizarre uh uh Craven
political advantage of many of these
Republicans they are now up against such
an example themselves because of a guy
that is being dubbed the Maga
masturbator I I
I don't know what to tell you guys a
republican Arizona candidate has been
caught masturbating outside of a
preschool and the story is absolutely
Bonkers HuffPost is reporting Arizona
Republican candidate arrested for
allegedly masturbating in a truck near a
preschool it's in none other than the
infamous Maricopa County Arizona where
officials say it's too late to remove
the the alleged perpetrator Randy
Kaufman from the ballot in the race for
a College District board dozens of you
emailing me about this the story is
roughly as follows again as reported by
Huffington Post Kaufman was arrested on
October 4th
but suspended his campaign earlier this
week following reports of his arrest
he was running for the governing board
of the Maricopa County Community College
District and was allegedly caught
masturbating by the County's Community
College Police I effed up Kaufman said
to an officer during the arrest
according to the police report which is
quite a document which you can find
online and read the report says the
incident started when an officer
approached Kaufman's parked vehicle and
saw that he had his pants down I'm not
going to read it exactly as it is
written but basically the officer was
able to ascertain by visual observation
of the individual's genitalia that there
was
manipulation taking place and it was all
um in view of a nearby bicyclist and a
preschool where little kids were playing
outside
when confronted according to the officer
Kaufman apologized and said I'm sorry I
effed up I'm really stressed really
really stressed and then said are you
going to put that in the report which
indeed the officer did yikes
uh don't you see how alarming that is
the officer responded there are children
nearby people passing on bikes and in
cars where they can look and see what
you're doing
notably in a Facebook post from May
Kaufman said he wanted quote our
children protected from the progressive
left
Kaufman was charged with public
indecency but 12 news in Phoenix
reported that Kaufman could also face a
possible felony charge because of his
proximity to the preschool so listen
what is the story here is the story that
Republicans endorse this stuff
no it's not and one of the things that
Republicans have been insisting upon and
we saw I mean I can't even name all of
the people that did it Kerry lake has
done it Marjorie Taylor green has done
it
um there's so many they they love to say
the Democrats are the party of
pedophilia and child abuse and all of
these different things and of course
they don't even have examples of it here
we have an actual Maga Republican who is
caught doing exactly what they love to
say the left welcomes and now they don't
want to say it has anything to do with
their party I'm willing to concede that
this is an individual actor but what we
can't continue allowing them to do is to
insist without evidence that the left is
the party of all this you know demonic
cabal of pedophiles and this that the
other thing without evidence when this
is not the only story like it that we
find about Republicans I'm not
I don't think my audience is so gullible
nor do I disrespect my audience so much
that now I'm going to say this behavior
is endorsed by the Republican party but
the point is their story about the left
their pedophiles and all this different
it's we've got to do something to not
allow them to continue repeating that uh
because it's the type of thing where you
go no no we're not and they go wow
that's exactly what the pedophiles would
be doing they would be denying it
there's got to be some way out of this
nonsense and there are too many of these
stories about right Wingers uh to go
unnoticed at this point in time